es del Ministerio de asuntos exteriores
de Irán una negación generalizada terar
insiste en que no ha tenido nada que ver
con el atentado contra salman rushy y
culpa al propio rage de su destino
salman ira y la furia popular al
insultar los sagrado del islam y
traspasar la línea rojas de más de 1.500
millones de musulmanes y también la de
Los Seguidores de toda la religiones
divinas el aclamado autor británico
indio se preparaba el viernes para
pronunciar un discurso en un centro
educativo en el oeste del estado de
Nueva York cuando un atacante se
abalanzó sobre el escenario apuñalándolo
10 veces sufrió graves daños en el brazo
y el hígado y se esperaba que perdiera
un ojo en estos momentos ya puede
respirar sin un ventilador según su
gente el escritor de 75 años está ahora
en vías de recuperación su agresor en
libanés estadounidense hadimatar de 24
años de Nueva Jersey fue sometido y
detenido en el lugar del ataque se ha
declarado No culpable de los cargos de
agresión e intento de asesinato desde su
revolución islámica de 1979 Irán con
frecuencia su participación en
operaciones contra disidentes y enemigos
a pesar de los indicios de lo contrario